First of all,
I didn't know the word longboard. People and when I went
to 5 public transportation or anywhere with a boom board,
what is the reaction of people?
If there is no reaction
like this
I think
co
[Music]
2 co 3
Hello, I'm a longboard in Korea with
only one goal.
Noon board literally means a gold board
.
Or giving a pop like this, I think you can call it a
favorite dog skateboard. It is a board that is easy to
harass, but
I like to ask. Among them, the three styles I have
are the Ascend Scene and Frick
. Behind the scenes overseas, Korea is a plane.
The style was 8 months earlier. In
Korea, there
are no villains in Korea where there is no bad place to live for practice or thread riding.
So, the tree style riding on flat ground
developed earlier.
I
'm thinking of cutting
it because my level
has risen
So I think it will be attractive
[Music]